[Music]
in my last video i talked about the
deeply emotional and touching moment of
liberation
that nico robin experienced at the top
of the tower of justice on anna's lobby
and so today i think it's just
appropriate to continue this elegantly
emotional journey
because
oh sorry i think i just played the wrong
clip here
as i was saying what makes robin's
character feel so
vulnerable and gentle
[Music]
uh what i really want to talk to you
about today
is how seamlessly and delicately oda has
designed here
okay you know what fine you're right
nothing sentimental today
let's talk epic and powerful let's talk
about blackbeard and why his infamous
speech on jaya
sets him up to be my favorite villain in
one piece
[Music]
one of the things that being stuck in
quarantine made me realize
besides the fact that i can stack
exactly 19 rolls of toilet paper to the
ceiling of my bathroom
is how god damn excited i am to see
luffy facing off blackbeard and his men
towards the end of the story
but at the same time i'm also incredibly
scared
what blackbeard might do to luffy before
they can face off in battle
like kidnapping robin or killing of
shanks
and i slowly started going down the
rabbit hole of all the blackbeard
theories out there and
what he might end up doing in the story
and so several youtube videos
a slightly too big can of coffee and a
short panic attack where i almost
spilled same kind of coffee across my
laptop later
i finally found myself confronted with
the question of all questions
how the hell do i love blackbeard so
much as a villain if he hasn't even
properly clashed yet with our hero
except for a very short skirmish and
impul down and
the answer to this question is exactly
this moment here
in mock town on jaya at the beginning of
the skypiya arc
it's an incredibly crafted scene by oda
filled to the brim
with comedy epicness and action that not
only foreshadows a whole lot of things
to come in the story
but also contains enormous symbolism for
one of the major themes of one piece
dreams so while this might admittedly be
a quite
harsh contrast to robin's moment on
endless lobby
i think you will agree with me that this
scene definitely belongs into our
the iconic scene analysis series
trademark
and so let's break this moment down and
see what makes it tick
as always i'll be starting with a short
recap of the moment that you can
but really shouldn't skip by going to
this time code up here
also if you want to follow along with
the manga we'll be discussing chapter
223
till 225 and episode 147 of the anime
let's roll the scene takes place shortly
after the crew arrives on jaya to
investigate the way to skypia
of which they found a map inside a ship
that had fallen from the sky
after arriving in mocktown the main town
of the island
nami makes luffy and zoro promise to not
fight and cause any commotion for them
while they're here
already foreshadowing that of course
there's going to be a commotion
shortly after leaving the ship they
encounter three strange men
each of which will later turn out to be
part of blackbeard's crew
the sniper van auger who is shooting
down birds from a rooftop
the sickly dog q who's giving out
explosive apples to strangers
as well as the wrestler jesus burgess
who was taking out countless people on
the street
these three quite unique and important
seeming figures
aren't revealed for who they truly are
until the straw hats leave for skypia
however
leaving the readers wondering what the
hell they've just seen here
now while wandering through the city
luffy nami and zorro
come across a fancy looking hotel
complex however immediately after
entering they're told that the
establishment is completely rented out
by the bellamy pirates
moments later one of bellamy's men
appears taking them for vagabonds and
throws some money at them
and the fact that nami doesn't take free
money here
i think speaks for itself after the
three straw heads leave
the pirate finds out about luffy's
bounty of 30 million barry and shares
this information with his captain
planning to take on luffy not knowing
that his bounty has already increased to
100 million
meanwhile luffy and co enter one of the
local pups in order to eat
there luffy sits next to a stuffy
looking man and for an entire hilarious
sequence of moments
both luffy and the man share the exact
identical reactions
except that while luffy hates the food
and loves the drinks
the man feels exactly the opposite they
start contending who can order the most
food
and in general seem very similar to each
other
luffy is ready to brawl with the man who
then asks him whether he's a pirate and
doesn't believe luffy when he says that
he has a 30 million barry bounty on his
head
he then leaves the pup just when bellamy
and his men arrive
mirroring shanks's encounter with the
mountain vanity gouma
the scene begins with a false sense of
goodwill
with bellamy buying luffy a drink before
he can take
a single zip however bellamy smashes his
head into the bar counter
before bellamy can enjoy his undeniably
very brave deto
too much zorro already has a blade right
at his throat
luffy also gets right back to his feet
preparing to fight bellamy
and nami trying to keep their goal in
mind
asks the bar keeper what he knows about
the sky islands as they plan to
journey there at these words bellamy and
all of his men gathered in the pub break
into laughter
switching from laughing to sudden anger
bellamy says that the age where pirates
have dreams is
over mentioning the city of gold the
emerald capital
and even the one piece and declares that
a new age is now coming looking
disgustedly at luffy he says that dreams
are for losers
at this moment something visibly changes
in luffy
and when bellamy and his men start
beating them up he tells zarro
not to do anything despite nami's pleads
to fight back now
falsely attributing their behavior to
their earlier promise not to fight
after bravely standing up to the pirates
taunts herself
she finally drags the bloody luffy and
zorro out of the pup
where in the middle of the square the
scruffy man from earlier is sitting
who apparently has decided to witness
the entire brawl from outside
he shouts at them that the sky islands
are real
and tells nami that zorro and luffy have
actually just won this fight
in this moment luffy remembers shanks
and ace and their expectations in him to
become a great pirate
the man meanwhile continues his epic
speech saying that the age where pirates
can dream is not
ending because a man's dream never ends
[Music]
while the people around him laugh at him
for being a madman
luffy and zorro stare back at him
without saying a single word
he tells luffy that the road to the top
isn't easy and that on the way there you
will always come across people
who aren't worth your fist and that he
hopes they will make it to the sky
islands
without any response the straw hats
leave and when nami wonders who the hell
this was
luffy and zara respond that it probably
wasn't him
but them and later on we find out that
this man was
indeed blackbeard and that just like
bellamy
he now has chosen luffy as his new
targets however
for the exact opposite reason
okay so let's dissect this bad boy of a
scene
if you didn't yet get yourself a cup of
coffee or tea
or you need a refill make sure that
you're well supplied and make yourself
comfortable
because there is a lot to talk about in
this video
[Music]
while this scene does a very solid job
in terms of body language framing etc
what makes this scene truly stand out as
an iconic one piece moment
in the iconic scene analysis series
trademark
is the enormous amount of symbolism it
carries
so in this analysis i will focus heavily
on this aspect and mention
other noteworthy elements as we go along
okay
so before we dive into the two heavy
themes of dreams
and dichotomy here there is one small
symbol i want to talk about first
as a sort of warm-up if you want mock
town
oda uses the name of the city here as a
symbol for the storyline itself
as luffy zoronami are being mocked for
their dreams by bellamy and his men
and bellamy is in turn mocked by
blackbeard for not having a dream in the
first place
oda loves to play around with location
names like this
where for instance logtown refers to the
words prologue and epilogue
as roger's journey started and ended
here and it also marks the end point of
the straw hat's prologue in the east
blue
before entering the grand line and
careful
very smooth transitioning coming of
course luffy enters the grand line to
fulfill his dream of becoming the freest
man in the world and find the one piece
nailed it okay let's talk about a man's
dream
or a woman's dream i guess actually
small fun fact when you read the
japanese original
blackbeard simply says
literally meaning a person's dream never
ends
so depending on the translation you've
read i might have just blown your mind
or not moving on i hope we're all on the
same page when i say that dreams are one
of
if not the biggest theme in one piece
it's for sure the theme of luffy and his
crew
and it also seems to play an important
role for the members of the d family
a topic that i think deserves an
entirely separate video on its own
dreams are the underlying driver of this
entire scene here on jaya
and play an enormous role in all the
major events surrounding it so
let's start with luffy's encounter with
bellamy and his men first
[Music]
the fundamental question in this moment
is why do luffy and zoro
not fight back here well the easiest
answer would of course be
that they promised nami not to cause a
commotion and they simply want to stay
true to their promise
however luffy was clearly prepared to
brawl with blackbeard over nothing more
than food earlier
and if we look at this panel here after
luffy gets back up
he also clearly is ready to fight
bellamy just as sorrow's ready having
his sword already at bellamy's throat
however after he and his men laugh at
nami for asking about the sky islands
and claiming that the era where pirates
can dream is over
and that fantasies like the golden city
or the one piece are
not worth pursuing luffy suddenly seems
to lose interest in him
why then was luffy ready to fight
blackbeard but not bellamy
now you might be tapping your fingers
thinking oh horror my man
obviously luffy didn't fight him because
shanks didn't fight the bandits either
back in fuchsia village
and i think you're definitely right in
that this moment with shanks
plays an important role here however i
think there's a lot more to it
the reason that shanks didn't fight back
against higuma and his men
was his pacifistic philosophy that
basically goes something like this
if there's no need to fight and no
imminent danger to my life or that of my
friends
there is no need for violence shanks was
obviously
light years out of higuma's reach and as
long as he only tried to humiliate him
there was no real reason to respond to
this and lower yourself to their level
the same goes for luffy in the situation
he knows that he's stronger than bellamy
which he also proves later on in the
story and even though he and zoro
actually get physically harmed
bellamy wasn't standing in the way of
luffy's goals or had hurt any of his
other friends
at least yet and so there was no real
need to fight back here
only when bellamy beats up montblanc
noland and takes away his goals
does luffy come back and beat bellamy
with one
single punch just as shanks took out all
of the bandits once they laid a hand on
luffy
of course luffy wants to become a great
pirate just like shanks and ace
and so reacting in the same way as his
mentor shows the character development
he has gone through since that moment in
the bar
where kid luffy was furious at shanks
for his behavior
which i think also shows the confidence
he has in his own powers
so yes the reference to shanks is
obviously very much intentional here
and there's a reason that luffy sees
both him and ace before his eyes during
blackbeard's speech
and we'll actually get back to this
later on as this i think might have a
second meaning as well
however if this attitude was the only
reason that luffy didn't fight
why the hell did he raise his fists in
the first place
now i think that there is another
criterium after which luffy decides
whether
or not someone is worth fighting next to
whether they're a threat or not
after all there are a number of fights
that luffy seems to truly enjoy and
cherish
and this criterium i think is a dream
does the person standing in front of him
have a dream
a will to fight for what he believes in
and is he striving to fulfill this dream
no matter what blackbeard clearly does
have a dream
and so luffy is more than willing to
brawl with him and take him for full
the same goes for instance for burgess
who challenges everyone in the streets a
little earlier
stating that he's the champion and luffy
and zoro want to fight him right away
the blackbeard pirates just like the
straw hats all have their very own dream
and will that they follow
no matter how much they might be polar
to each other in terms of values and
morality
what bellamy does when laughing at their
wish to find the sky islands and
spitting on the era of pirate streaming
is giving a clear sign for luffy that
this man has no dream
and thus no will of his own thus he's
not on the same level as him
and since he's no immediate threat he's
not worth fighting
as zora later confirms when asked by
nami about this
luffy felt nothing but pity for bellamy
in this moment
who's used and disregarded by the man he
admires
doflamingo being a celestial dragon and
thus the arc nemesis
of those that have dreams is wonderfully
set up in this moment here by oda
and the pity that luffy feels for the
dream and will is bellamy
is something that he beautifully
references again on dressrosa
when luffy calls bellamy's friend and
ultimately wants to free him from
doflamingo's control
and so the only reason i believe that
luffy goes back to fight bellamy
is because he knows that the gold city
is mon blanc's dream
and by stealing his gold the only proof
that held the old man stream together
bellamy had mocked his stream as well
and taken it away
luffy might be naive and at times a bit
slow on the uptake
but his sense for what is pure is
incredible he believes in friendship
dreams and dying for what you believe in
this is just one way that oda
illustrates that for us
but i think it's really hard to see that
if you don't believe in dreams yourself
now the entire theme of dreams then goes
full circle
before leaving skypia and after knocking
on bellamy
one of his men asks luffy where he's
going to which luffy replies showing
that
nothing can stop him from following his
dreams
finally after defeating eno luffy rings
the golden bell of shandora
and his shadow can be seen in the sky by
noland and his men
thus luffy has confirmed that the golden
city actually exists
legitimizing his dream and opposing
bellamy's initial mocking of both of
their dreams
okay let's talk about blackbeard as you
might have realized blackbeard directly
references roger's last words here with
his speech
and whether or not he was actually
present as roger's funeral
what oda pretty much foreshadows with
his parallel here
is that blackbeard is also a d just like
luffy and roger
he is driven by his dream which involves
finding the one piece
now of course whatever history might be
it's most likely a lot more
self-centered than luffy's
but it's still without any doubt true
that both characters share an insane
amount of similarities
and so this is the second big theme of
the scene that we have to talk about
dichotomy or to be more precise the
dichotomy between blackbeard and luffy
let's look at their very first encounter
in the bar
when both of them are eating one loves
the pie and hates the lemonade
whereas the other things the contrary it
just shows how perfectly opposed they
are
they think the same way but have
perfectly opposed points of view on
what's good and what's bad
the framing here wonderfully supports
this impression as both are shown side
by side for several panels
and it seems very deliberate by oda
who's basically telling us here
yeah these guys are gonna be rivals
blackbeard's character is what writers
call a foil
a character who shares many of the same
traits and characteristics as the main
character
but differs in some critical ways and is
usually set against him
luffy and teach are similar in many core
ways
and started their journey in similar
fashions coming from humble beginnings
the story builds these characters up
over time showing their struggles their
limits
and how they overcome these obstacles to
grow to greater heights
they both understand the need for
teamwork and have a very simple
goal-driven mindset however whereas
luffy gains strength and infamy through
courage
justice and honest ambition teach
advances
through deception murder and the
exploitation of the weakness of others
despite their shared attitude that
dreams should never be given up on
the dichotomy of their methods resonates
with the story arc
and so bringing the conversation back to
the theme of dreams
you could say that blackbeard chose the
easy way to achieve his dream
since he did what was necessary but not
what was right
luffy in contrast will achieve his
dreams with his crewmates
and most likely they are even an active
part of his dream in the first place
and so i think it's almost poetic when
you think that blackbeard doesn't
actually sleep
in other words he doesn't even have real
dreams to begin with
this is so deep now the way that oda
introduces teach in the scene by the way
might be my favorite introduction of any
villain
ever first of all i think for all the
issues i've had with the one piece anime
over the years
the casting of blackbeard's voice actor
might have been the best thing they've
ever come up with
akio otsuka that man simply has the
perfect range of voice for this
character
and i love every single line he says
and the way that the iconic panel itself
simply blows out the entire background
and noise around them
focusing solely on blackbeard opposing
the three straw hats
is wonderful visual foreshadowing for
the future conflict between the two
but also for the similarities between
them and
speaking of foreshadowing the way that
luffy sees ace and shanks before his
eyes
makes me wonder whether this is some
sort of foreshadowing as well
ace has already been taken out by
blackbeard and shanks
also has a special relationship with him
just some food for thought here
what i also think is interesting is how
luffy's and also zoro's attitude
totally changes towards blackbeard and
how their words tsunami
have given rise to a number of wild
speculations about blackbeard's powers
i don't want to delve too far into these
but simply from an analysis perspective
i think it becomes clear that luffy sees
another person sitting in the square
than who he saw in the pub this
blackbeard here
is not the blackbeard that sat next to
him eating pie
and so luffy just stares at him making
clear that he can't be
fooled this reaction might also
ultimately have been the reason that
blackbeard decided to take luffy out
fearing that he might become his
greatest rival chasing the one piece
[Music]
okay so what is the overall purpose of
this scene
as mentioned at the beginning of this
video this scene is packed to the brim
with symbolism
the scene works strongly with the
overarching theme of dreams that is also
reflected in the introduction of luffy's
main antagonist in the story
the way oda introduces blackbeard is
refreshingly creative
since our first impressions of
blackbeard come to us from the stories
that we hear about him
prior to this official introduction we
know for instance that he scared wahpo
badly enough to cause him to abandon
drum island
and that ace is hunting him because he
killed a fellow shipmate
okay it shouldn't be too hard to
identify this ruthless pirate right
but when we are first introduced to the
man we would later come to know his
blackbeard
the very first thing he does is get into
a fight with luffy about whether the
cherry pie
tastes good or not this guy here feels
important to us
but certainly not in a bad way only at
the end of the scene do we really know
the truth about who we just met
this is truly a fantastic moment in the
story
that without any doubt deserves a spot
on our list
and so while luffy and blackbeard got a
whole lot of character development in
this scene
who also deserves some praise here i
feel was zorro
who stood next to his captain and took
the beating without any complaints
how did zorro become such a loyal
partner for luffy
well i'm glad you asked because we'll be
looking at that in the next video
thanks guys peace